I gotta say you nailed it in this film
like you reminded me of people that I
knew growing up and in the school that
made me feel like I was back like I was
like I was young again you're right how
important was it for you guys to get
that right the theme of being young
being in love and also how like mental
health and and issues can affect
relationships mmm yeah I think that was
that was kind of a the intertwining of
that and reading the book of how nuanced
that is and you know of showing love but
also how that you know that love can
also be affected by mental health and
and what that does to a relationship and
I think the film also doesn't answer all
your questions his life doesn't answer
all your questions I think it's it's
very a sophisticated version and it
doesn't talk down to young people which
was really it's really important that
was something that I loved so much and I
also like how its it talks about I feel
like there's this message that's
idealistic in in the zeitgeist that's
like love kind of cures at all like love
yeah answer which which it is it's like
so important in healing and moving
forward but what's equally as impotent
as important is like love for your
yourself and
and allowing yourself to make mistakes
and to not feel guilty for going through
something and opening yourself up to
getting help and yeah so that's
something I really liked about the film
and the chemistry is great between you
two did you feel it on set like what did
you say to each other the first time you
guys were on set together first day my
first day was the bike I remember this
we were didn't get photo to the photo
with the sticky notes and laughing
because we didn't know each other before
yeah yeah but then like now we're like
so we're so close yeah I mean like you
you you do a film like that and you're
also the film requires you to go through
a lot of emotions and you're you know
with like justice is like my partner in
that and like we're in it together and
to be vulnerable with each other of
course you're gonna get closer
[Laughter]
yeah yeah did you guys when you add the
roller-coaster did you like we gotta do
this without doing the tape yeah we
gotta go do we get to ride at once
off-camera - I forgive ya so the first
note Brett wanted to get off yeah that's
you yeah there's like a lot of like
insurance
oh yeah when you guys are finding
yourself in a dark place who or what do
you turn to to help you guys like get
back to a bright place my sister is the
person who pushes me forward and keeps
me going
she's my best friend I love her so much
Hey she's coming tonight you'll meet her
oh yeah he has like eight siblings yeah
oh gosh I mean my family is like I lean
on them for everything
I think yep for myself it's like I just
need to allow myself to feel all my
feelings like sometimes I bury those
feelings and for me it's important to
just like have that big cry or like that
big scream or just like dance or laugh
hysterically and like honestly I feel
like I feel really cleansed
like I feel so much better after just
those big